welcome into this video playing Fran Sir
Francis lark that I'm butchering totally
okay let's see we got before different
maybe I can do something for a change
the Queen point game London which is not
bad especially if black is committed to
e6 it's a pretty decent alternative to
the normal moose okay let's keep this
Bishop the normal moose is wrong way to
tear to them to say it to the Queens
gambit I mean you can you can really
play that once in a while okay let's
post this up on e5 try to ok it seems
that he has something in store their
night f5 coming ok don't want Bishop a
six so easily so put the Queen down 95
is a decent idea here maybe trying to
get my g3 bishop I think I'm yeah I'm
almost forced to capture now so let's
capture may be here to irritate him a
little bit this pin ok so he's allowing
Knight to c6 surprisingly I mean it's
not clear that it helps much but let's
do it Jeff
I think okay well he has Bishop a 6 I
shouldn't forget about this it's quite
important
he also has c4 possibly how do i how do
i set up well against yeah maybe maybe
this one getting out of bishop a six and
having a look at the 95 pawn that's a
slightly better pawn structure here so
it's nothing great but it's it's okay so
yeah it's an interesting moment now I
was thinking maybe I can just take on c5
and play Knight be 34 the pawn structure
I'm flirting Bishop f6 let's do that
threatening Bishop f6 yeah Queen takes
Knight c5 winning this pawn and well how
does he cover c5
I don't think you can play in some way
with Bishop f6 gtx f6 with the triple
pawn it would be quite amazing 1c4 I'm
happily going to oh I didn't see that
move oh that's not good yeah and I can
take f 64 look f 6 9 a-5 just just
snatching this pawn but it doesn't look
right it really doesn't okay on in other
cases he just goes a form so i have to
take the pawn even though i don't like
it very much miss placing this night
there Formiga porn yeah probably that
whole idea wasn't separate
oh maybe I'm sure negative there it's a
porn after all but I'm not sure maybe
you can get some kind of activity chance
hard to not treat Queen Sam and so let's
do it and now be for a while fighting
for the dark squares
okay rook t1 I guess my ideas night be
three try to force him to move the
Seaport so that i get the default square
for the night and if i get dead end I'm
really controlling the position very
nicely okay yeah if not be sewn double
attacking c5 and the rook yeah I don't
know maybe it was okay this is Pawn grab
on a five but black resigned to their
that's not not much you can do them
let's let's have a look that I wasn't I
wasn't sure about many things in this
game so that all looks nice here he went
there okay and I went for this this
thing I don't know I actually blundered
bishop a six-year uh yeah after that I
don't have a great move I mean this blah
ok I forgot about this totally numb that
was bad he should have done that of
course Bishop a six yeah here I'm champ
a bit better yeah it's funny the
computer here here's stockfish it
actually wants to play this position
here and says it's equal yeah if you
assess this is equal you really really
believe in the power of bishops or let's
say okay it's a matter of activity black
ass fairly active here with those pawns
and B 2 and so on maybe it looks likely
the different difficult decision to to
make yeah probably
here I'm winning them yeah the computer
agrees I'm getting the dark squares yeah
Queenie voice then giving it giving it
away this is what the engine is
suggesting yeah something like that it's
not clear at all I cannot move the pawns
forward quickly and yeah wait I cannot
go before I cannot move the pods forward
quickly and Jeff what am I doing here I
can try to convert this is Pawn very
very slowly but it's not very it's not
very comfortable this position Black has
a decent compensation comp is on 0.3 or
something so it's it's okay yeah biggest
thing was he had Bishop a six at one
point okay well thanks for watching